alors on a fait le top 10 des tweets les
plus drôles alors depuis qu'on sait
qu'on se dirige petit à petit vers le
confinement générale à paris c'est un
peu la panique regardez les parisiens
regardez les parisiens voilà les
parisiens qui fuit tout contact le
parisien voilà parisiens ont fui ont
tout contact avec le corps d'un virus à
ses énormes en neuvième il ya leeza
leeza leeza camon qui a remarqué que
depuis qu'il est question de confinement
on n'a pas de chance il fait super beau
on n'a qu'une envie c'est d'aller dans
un parc ou en terrasse elle a raison
c'est incroyable depuis qu'elle
confinement il a jamais fait aux
secondes sur la france
on dirait qu'ils nous ont mis à jeter un
sort mon frère sur ma vie c'est un truc
de ouf numéro 8
regardez-le avantage d'être chez soi
c'est qu'on peut se faire livrer des
doses sur des créneaux super large dans
de 8h à 20h regarder ce tweet ça aussi
très drôle
chronopost petite pensée pour tous les
livreurs chronopost qui ne pourront plus
dire qu'on n'était pas à la maison
il ya davantage de cette quarantaine
c'est qu'elle devrait relancer la
natalité française
regardez ça c'est beau saoudien huit
mois après le coronavirus et la
quarantaine voilà c'est magnifique en
numéro 6 mon ami je suis sûr que cette
histoire de confinement va nous faire du
bien on voit déjà que les gens sont plus
prévoyants font plus attention aux
autres
regardez merci de ne pénétrer qu'une
personne la vie quotidienne en france
autant du côté du confinement et penser
au gel ça c'est patron de m on a en
cinquième position
emmanuel macron l'a dit nous sommes en
guerre mais il ya encore des internautes
qui ont du mal à y croire
regardez ce à quoi je m'attends ce pour
le contrôle des attestations versus la
réalité tu as aussi très drôle en numéro
4 on a une grosse pensée pour tous les
gens qui sont confinés chez eux tout
seul ou en tête à tête avec leur chat
regardez ces france y est la soirée
confinement avec le chat elles vont
tourner en rond les conversations c'est
à dire on aime bien en numéro 3 des
tweets les plus hall en italie en
espagne il ya plein de vidéos on voit
des gens qui chantent en choeur depuis
leur balcon en france visiblement c'est
pas encore la même ambiance
regardez ça j'ai voulu chanter au balcon
comme en espagne j
ta gueule et 5 c'est pas les bonnes
paroles mais non au numéro 2 pour
l'instant tout le foot européen est
suspendu on ne sait pas si la ligue 1 va
reprendre mais ça n'empêche pas l'équipe
de toulouse derrière dernière du
championnat de se faire tailler
je me suis fait un masque avec le
maillot du gardien du tfc
vu qu'ils n'attrapent jamais rien voilà
ça c'est par contre aussi et enfin en
numéro 1 le tweet le plus drôle pour
nous je vous le dis depuis hier c'est
mon préféré on a trouvé ça sur facebook
d'ailleurs il ya des gens qui confondent
pharmacie et sex shop
regardez quand on te demande de te munir
d'un masque et de gel mais t'as pas bien
compris ça c'est génial c'est bon c'est
magnifique mais ça le continuer
franchement continuer à essayer de nous
faire marrer